à barcelone comme dans toutes les villes
d'espagne
les commerces sont de plus en plus
nombreux à baisser définitivement le
rideau entre la baisse du tourisme les
restrictions en vigueur et la chute de
la consommation
la fréquentation des établissements a
baissé en moyenne de 40 % comme ailleurs
les activités de service sont les
principales victimes de la crise
sanitaire
bilan un taux de chômage qui culmine à
16,1 pour cent de la population active
contre 13,7 pour cent l'an passé un
record au sein de l'union européenne
le secteur est à l'arrêt nous n'avons
pas du tout travaillé depuis l'année
dernière
au début on pensait pouvoir retravailler
l'été dernier où à la fin de l'été mais
ça n'a pas été le cas est arrivée la
deuxième vague puis la troisième on
espère qu'il n'y en aura pas d'autre et
voilà où on en est complètement à
l'arrêt et sans perspectives réelles de
date de reprise
avec plus de 4 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi auxquels il faut ajouter les
900 mille salariés actuellement en
chômage partiel
l'espagne fait face à sa plus grave
crise économique depuis 2012
si le gouvernement a déboursé plus de 40
milliards d'euros pour soutenir
l'économie
depuis le début de la pandémie les aides
publiques demeurent insuffisantes et mal
utilisé selon de nombreux analystes
économiques
non il n'y a pas d' aides directes aux
entreprises comme cela a été le cas en
allemagne ou en france pour les
indemniser des pertes qu'elles ont eues
et pour sauver l'intérêt général
il y ait beaucoup d'entreprises comme
des restaurants des hôtels qui ont fermé
au bénéfice de toute la population
elle aurait dû être aidé directement pas
seulement leur offrant des facilités de
crédit parce que le crédit augmentent
l'endettement et quand les restrictions
seront terminés il faudra rembourser ce
crédit
donc c'est une barrière supplémentaire
qui peut devenir un frein à la reprise
preuve de ses difficultés actuelles
l'espagne a vu son pib s'effondrer de 11
% en 2020 autre mauvaise nouvelle le
fonds monétaire international a revu ses
prévisions de croissance à la baisse
madrid pour désormais sur la vaccination
et le passeport sanitaires pour tenter
d'enrayer l'épidémie et relancer une
économie bien mal en point